never assign a probability of zero or
one hundred to any claim
[Music]
there's a kind of tribalism to which
conspiracy theories people believe so
Republicans have their own set Democrats
have their own set so in one sense
conspiracy theories are losers as they
say whoever loses the election thinks
the other side cheated I see Robert
Kennedy Jr just this morning tweeted out
that uh that we all know these elections
are rigged and just because we don't
like Donald Trump doesn't mean you know
they're not actually doing these things
because Al Gore had the election stolen
in 2000 by George W bush and we know
that was a fraudulent election well hang
on so now there's a Democrat saying you
know this is a real conspiracy all sides
do this everybody thinks the other
side's up to no good and that's just in
politics so that kind of tribal
conspiracism applies to religious
beliefs economic ideology economic
commitments ideologies any kind of
cultural belief if my group thinks it's
true then there must be something to it
so there's a lot of interesting research
in cognitive psychology on
this kind of tribal commitment to a
particular belief or not right so if you
take something like climate change do
you accept it as real and human caused
or not
well the the best predictor of this is
your political affiliation if you're
more right-leaning you're more skeptical
if you're more left-leaning you're more
accepting of it in fact most people
don't really know what the science is
behind climate science it's a it's a
technical field and who has time or
intelligence or education to read the
technical papers so we all rely on
secondary sources or tertiary sources
media sources and what does my tribe
tell me is reasonable to accept so like
an evolution and creationism debates
you know the predictor there is what
your religious attitudes are or what
your attitudes are towards science so if
you ask this is research by a guy named
Andrew stuhlman at Occidental College in
Los Angeles you ask people do you accept
the theory of evolution by natural
selection okay the people that say yes
and then you ask them what is it explain
it
they actually don't know they'll give
some lamarckian Theory all the giraffes
stretch its neck and then the babies
have longer no that isn't actually what
it is
so and so it's not just that the
creationists if they only understood the
theory of evolution they'd be accepting
of no because the people that accept it
they don't know it either
additional studies you know in America
we have this big naftra the North
American Free Trade Agreement there's a
big thing with Trump and before that
with Obama and so on so people that
signal I I like NAFTA I support NAFTA or
I don't like I don't think we should be
a naftra what is it it's that you know
the thing that that North uh free it's
something about trade I don't even know
who's in it but I'm against it or I'm
for it so these are tribal uh beliefs
and we all do this because who has time
to check all that stuff and so you know
these are to a certain extent kind of an
underlying rationality that seems on the
surface irrational if you're wrong but
in fact because we're social creatures
we have to rely on what other people are
telling us or doing or else how would
you know
so even kind of reinterpreting some of
the famous social psych experiments from
the 60s and 70s the sort of gorilla
theater social science where they you
know lie to the subjects like one you
have the subjects in a room uh filling
out a form we did I did a replication of
this for Dateline NBC so it was pretty
amusing to watch so everybody in the
room is a just an actor working for us
we got the one person in there filling
out the form they're trying out for this
talk this reality show
and so we start pumping in theater smoke
underneath the door
and no one all our actors are told just
sit there and keep filling out the form
so they do and so you know the salute
there are Target you know he just he's
looking around like well
um uh well all right it I'm just
gonna keep writing and you know they
just so this is called
it's kind of Conformity to the group and
you know this kind of foolish psychology
but is it really because if we were in
this room right now and there was smoke
coming in my guess is most of you would
not just sit there
so my taking cues from you is usually a
pretty accurate reading of the world
it's kind of the pull the audience kind
of a collective wisdom of the crowd kind
of thing usually works pretty well for
basic things like that
um or you know milgram's shock
experiments uh you know what's the
proper interpretation of that you know
15 bolts at a time before you know it
the guy's all the way up to 350 volts
and so why are they doing this well
obedience to Authority yeah but what
what does that mean it means really that
blind that these people really that
irrational
uh because you know there you're at a
university setting here's a professor in
a lab coat they can't really be having
me kill somebody with electricity really
so we we replicated that in this date in
this uh NBC studio and of course it's a
it's a television producer telling them
to administer these shocks they want to
be on this reality show so there's a
kind of logic to well yeah I know it
seems bad but you know this guy's a TV
producer this is NBC they can't actually
be having me kill people can they you
know um so let me just give some
background so in cognitive psychology
the question is are we naturally
rational or irrational do we default to
truth
and believe whatever anybody tells us
are we naturally skeptical
and so this is kind of a debatable topic
I I tend to think for the most part in
most contexts we're reasonably rational
and it takes a lot to get somebody to
really do something foolish join the
cult or whatever so if you just take any
of these uh stories you hear about
people that join occult like Jim's uh
Jim Jones is Jonestown or the Heaven's
Gate cult or any of those Scientology we
have that in La I'm from Southern
California they're all over the place
you can take the personality test and
everybody fails you got to take this
course to help your personality or you
hold the cans and you do the little
e-meter reading and you spike it by just
squeezing it and then you know that
leads to a whole series of questions
okay so how many people and you've seen
the documentaries about all these groups
you know this guy right there he's the
one that gave him a hundred thousand
dollars all right so that's the example
we're showing how many people did they
have to go through to get that guy to
write that check
right and we're not told what's the base
rate you know you know compared to what
how irrational is this person and how
many steps did it take to get them there
to actually take out the checkbook and
write the check and when you look into
it carefully it's a lot it's you know
like months or years of this kind of
programming somebody
I was thinking about this um there was a
Netflix documentary called series called
um the Tinder swindler are you familiar
with this the Tinder swindler all right
so it's a half a dozen of these uh women
and they're maybe mid to late 30s
looking for love they want to get buried
have kids the whole thing they meet this
guy they've met a bunch of guys most of
them you know it doesn't work out all
right so here's a guy with a picture
with a private jet
all right this guy he could be
bullshitting me but you never know you
know how guys are but so I'll just meet
with them and see how it goes right
because he's a good looking guy and
maybe he's got money anyway so the first
date they're on the jet they go to this
five-star Resort on an island in this
and this goes on and on for weeks and
months and the women are holding up
their phones look at the text you know
hundreds and hundreds and you know I
love you and we're gonna have a baby
together you're the one on and on and on
and on and
you know and then it turns out that he's
an international Man of Mystery he goes
off to Morocco one weekend after like
six months into this relationship
they're gonna get married the whole
thing and then he calls her oh I'm stuck
in Morocco the bank is closed I'm
closing this 20 million dollar deal I
need ten thousand dollars right now
because the bank doesn't open till
Monday so now if you're that person
you know of course if I tell you this
you go I would never send them ten
thousand are you sure because if you
give the whole build up the Thousand
little things that happened for six
months are you really going to say to
the person you want to marry and have uh
start a family with this person you're
just going to go no
you know so so they do right so by the
end of this show you're thinking these
these people are idiots to give this guy
money well I'm not so sure how
irrational that is and also what we
don't know because these things are
carefully edited how many women did this
guy go through to get the one that sent
him the 50 000 bucks and some of them
gave like 150 000 uh to get to that
point right so we don't know that you
know the people that joined Jim Jones is
um Group in San Francisco this was a
very liberal Progressive integrated
church one of the first integrated
churches in the United States he's from
Indiana he moved to San Francisco
because they didn't allow integrated
groups like that it was against the law
in the 1950s so there he is Manning the
soup kitchens and helping the poor and
integrating black and white this is very
Cutting Edge right so you people that
join that group that was a good thing
that was completely rational and
reasonable Cutting Edge ahead of you
know on the right side of history and it
is until 20 years later that a handful
of them a couple hundred moved to Guyana
after a thousand Little Steps along the
way okay so my point is that I tend to
think humans are fairly rational in the
right context
and that most of the time we just do go
through our day in a reasonably rational
way
and that the standouts that that the
exceptions really take quite a an effort
to get somebody to fall for that
particular thing and so I side on the
side of mostly rational
if you give people the tools of how to
think about particular claims which is
you know what I do here you know I like
to think we can teach people how to be
rational uh and so but there are I mean
we've learned a lot in you know the last
couple centuries on how science Works
what should you believe you know
knowledge Justified true belief well
what's Justified how is it Justified how
do you know if you should believe this
or that and so then there's a whole
series of kind of tools you can apply to
any particular claim
that you hear in the media or whatever
how should you think about the climate
Skeptics how do you know the climate
Skeptics are wrong I assume most people
here probably accept anthropogenic
global warming I do but why
you know I can't I read people send me
these papers I'm not a climate scientist
I don't really know what they say so but
I trust that the process works
reasonably well and that the scientists
themselves are competitive they try to
debunk each other by the time it filters
out to me in a Popular Science magazine
or whatever story I read about climate
change and you know the glaciers and the
CO2 levels and all that stuff it's like
yeah okay you know they they're probably
getting it right even though I don't
really understand it because the system
itself is reasonably trustworthy not
always they may be wrong and you can
apply that to you know well the recent
covet the vaccines should we vac masks
okay so here's an example of where
there's a lot of ignorance where we just
don't know
and so errors are made and then people
so there's been a kind of collapse of
trust of science and medicine because of
uh the mistakes made during covet but
that doesn't discount the whole thing
because that's what happens when we
don't know
right if it's going to be like Ebola and
you know 50 million people in every
country die or if it's just going to be
like a a bad flu nobody knew at the time
some people think they knew but I don't
go that far that that would be a little
bit too much of a conspiracy theory but
even that you know just say
parenthetically the lab leak hypothesis
I always thought that was reasonable and
then all of a sudden you can't talk
about that or Twitter is gonna you know
cancel you or whatever I'd always
thought that was unreasonable because it
could be
you know that kind of thing it wasn't it
wasn't a conspiracy theory like the
Chinese intentionally did this
uh just an accident because accidents
happen that kind of thing but so that
you know there's the underlying
principle there is you have to have
complete open Free Speech dialogue
conversation listen to the Skeptics
in this case not me I mean the like the
people that are skeptical of vaccines or
whatever it's okay
you know let watch Joe Rogan and you
know talk about these things that's okay
didn't watch some other show and you
know and you just know what you're
getting just by getting more information
that's the only way we can find out
what's true is by talking to other
people because
uh well to put it this way you're not
God and neither am I
or if you prefer the secular version
there is an objective reality only I
don't know what it is and you don't
either so we have to work on this
together and never assign a probability
of zero or one hundred to any claim and
always it's possible that the outsider
could be right you know just in case you
should keep a little door open right
there in Bayesian reasoning this is
called cromwell's Rule Oliver Cromwell
famously said I beseech you in the
bowels of Christ you might be mistaken
right so the the Bayesian The Cromwell
rule is never assign a zero to anything
just in case uh keep an open mind so
it's like um uaps UFOs unidentified
aerial phenomena sounds so much more
sophisticated than goofy UFOs but
um so what do you make when you see yet
another one of these posted yesterday of
these kind of triangular shaped object
above a military base in the United
States what is it to me it looks like
flares at night because you can't make
you know so the eye kind of connects the
dots of the flares that are floating in
this triangular shape for some reason
the UFOs the aliens always come in
triangle shape spacecraft I'm not sure
why that is so how should we think about
yet another one of those and they they
come up every couple of days every
couple weeks so here's how to think
about it in a Bayesian way so you take
the pro ufologists who think absolutely
we are being visited by aliens
and then they say that and there's been
tens of thousands of sightings and
stories and so on they say that 95 of
all those are fully explainable by
natural phenomena they are flocks of
geese they are flares they are uh drones
they're Chinese spy balloons uh you know
they are swamp gas they're the planet
Venus they're you know there's a hundred
of these different explanations
that are not aliens they're not super
Advanced Russian Chinese drone
technology that we don't have or
anything like that so now so here's the
bin the bin is you know 95 and here's
two other little bins aliens super
Advanced drone technology okay so a new
one comes down
there it is oh my God there's the video
I saw it on Twitter what is it what
should I think that it probably is
in the Big 95 bin or the two little tiny
two and a half percent bins right okay
not impossible could be this is the one
you know aliens have finally come here
finally after all these now this is the
one or it's probably here we just don't
know what it is yet right so again you
don't have to go black or white it's
definitely not or it definitely is just
say it's probably here it's probably not
one of these Maybe
if it turns out it is then I want to see
unmistakable evidence like the Chinese
five balloon there it is Big pictures
quite clear you can see the the
equipment hanging from the bottom of the
balloon you can see the jets flying up
to it shooting it down there's the
debris in the ocean you can see them
dragging the debris up we have pictures
of there it is end of story right that's
Justified true belief
so when you're confronted with these
anomalies you don't have to do anything
with them
just keep an open mind just say okay I
don't know I'll sign graduate students
to figure that out they have to have
something to do right so here you know
is the problem of anomalies back to
conspiracies and that no theory of
anything explains a hundred percent of
the facts
so we're always going to be left with
the residue of anomalies unexplained
things how do you explain it and the
problem is we can't explain everything
so it's okay to just say I don't know
it might be what you think it is
two little bends or it might be yet
another one here in the big bin but
let's wait and see right so and this is
true and you know any alternative
um hypothesis like my friend Grant
Hancock the alternative archaeologist
right he's got a laundry list of
anomalies that mainstream archaeologists
cannot explain or at least he says they
can't and if you watch or you watch the
ancient alien shows right they have
every show is here's an anomaly can you
explain that one thing right there and
if you can't then that proves Atlantis
or the ancient aliens or the super
Advanced ancient civilization whatever
no it doesn't prove anything it just
proves that we don't know everything
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas